let's let's talk about how joe biden may
be presiding over the end of american
global dominance from the wall street
journal saudi arabia considers accepting
yuan instead of dollars for chinese oil
sales
talks between riyadh and beijing have
accelerated as the saudi saudi
unhappiness grows with washington now
there's two big points to make your
first some people are screaming it's
fake news don't believe it and there's
some reporting coming out saying it's
not true it's not true it's not going to
happen
however what we do know as i mentioned
in the previous segment even trevor noah
criticized joe biden because saudi
arabia refused to take his call we also
know they invited xi jinping to the
country at the same time we're hearing
reports that they're considering trading
oil in yuan what this will do is it's
going to strengthen
chinese currency and their government
and their economy substantially
it's going to send signals to everybody
that if if saudi arabia does this
because they trade exclusively in u.s
dollars
that it's good for you to have you on
because you can buy oil with it now
that is
the the first you know chipping away of
us global dominance in terms of the
petrodollar the reserve currency and
what what americans need to understand
is that a large portion of the wealth we
have wealth we have comes from the fact
that we are the progenitors of reserve
currency around the world if that ends
we have very little to offer everybody
else yeah exactly i mean think about how
much the value of our dollar is boosted
by the fact that everybody has to
purchase u.s dollars if they want to buy
oil from saudi arabia i think it's not
just saudi arabia too yeah exactly
yeah i think as saudi as uh like the
nozzle on the hose like the garden
nozzle that you squeeze to squirt it and
if and we are the hose you know we're
producing the the fluid that's coming
through this hose but if saudi wants to
twist shut we have no more way to get
that oil out to the world if they don't
want to sell in u.s dollars that's like
the tip of the species so does this also
make inflation much worse if we printed
all this money and now all these foreign
governments are no longer possessing it
yeah exactly if they start dumping it
then we're going to have dollar bills in
the streets being shoveled into the
gutter and i just don't understand how
people could be too shocked that we
present printed what 80 percent of the
dollars in existence over the past 20
years there's something along those
lines in circulation yeah sorry in
circulation i mean
of course we're just going to be inching
towards losing our status as world
reserve currency why would anyone be
willing to depend on our currency well
this is why the white house is so
desperate they called in the tick
tockers to lie to young people they're
going to also it's not our currency the
u.s dollar is federal reserve currency
it's a private but we don't have the
congress doesn't control it anymore what
bothers me the most about what the white
house did with these tick tockers it's
basically just like spitting on these
kids
like kids who are finally asking why is
my gas seven bucks in l.a that's one
thing that this this young woman said
she was like we want to know why gas
around the corner is seven dollars a
gallon it's because of putin and i'm
like it's not
it's literally not because of like ask
yourself why california has seven dollar
a gallon and you go to arizona or
colorado it's four dollars but that's
the oldest mind control game in the book
is you need a common enemy when things
are tough you need a distraction and you
get everyone worked up and now we're in
war mode and we've got an enemy so we're
all going to come together
dude after 9 11 it was the craziest mass
formation psychosis people wanted to
blood they wanted to be in the middle
east and then they're like and iraq and
they're like yeah whatever man i'm
hungry feed me look at what they're
doing with ukraine now
there's a comic mocking leftists and i'm
seeing leftists post it so i'm actually
like good where it's like
russia says you know uh there's weapons
of mass destruction and they're like oh
you know okay we're okay with that now
like the the united states invaded iraq
because of weapons of mass destruction
boone's got women's mass destruction we
can invade russia no of course not
because russia is actually a threat to
us the issue is you have all these
leftists who pretended to be anti-war
who said war is bad and now that ukraine
is is all in the press and all the media
they're all waving the flag saying we
got to do something and they also
impeached trump for suggesting
essentially that biden had some oddly
close relationship with ukraine and sure
enough it's seeming like he does i think
it's undisputed that he his son was on
the board of charisma well that is
undisputed yeah it's indisputable for
sure biden is interwoven in that
ukrainian right but he was trying to
claim like oh it's no big deal that's
just my son i don't know like he's
clearly like obsessed with ukraine and
has been for years and that was kind of
at the heart of you know the impeachment
is trump was kind of right like why why
are you into ukraine so much dude like
it really doesn't have anything to do
with us i i'm just asking do you think
it was that he just wants the landmass
to to move oil or is there something
more i mean this is just a wild i don't
know if you have the answer to this but
what do you think it is why biden's been
obsessed with ukraine for so long
oh i have no clue other than you know i
i mean we know that obviously his son
has a lot of money ties there but i have
no no clue oh boy it's like the bread
basket of yours walking over and grabbed
their water but come on ian either
russia we talk about cover this all the
time either russia or europe wants that
ukrainian bread basket they want to know
their country
about 20 of natural gas i believe goes
through ukraine from the company gazprom
which russia controls
this allows russia to control prices and
make them very very high so what we end
up seeing in in europe is energy prices
are pretty high what happened when
france tried putting a small petrol tax
on the on the people for climate change
reasons so they claimed climate change
people rioted for a year and a half so
the u.s and and western interests
destabilize
the middle east which syria
somehow uh we start seeing western
resources like mike's plumbing end up in
the hands of jihadis
you know oh yeah
u.s support for rebels the u.s allies
supporting isis
and it was destabilizing assad very very
convenient for us because we wanted to
get rid of him so we could build our
pipeline to offset the gas prop gas
monopoly then you get
you know uh trump comes in
trump flattens isis russia's like okay
good my ally is secure trump was doing
things that was ending war it's a good
thing isis is bad got rid of it this
de-escalated tensions between russia and
the west that's a good thing joe biden
gets in and what happens immediately you
start seeing that you start seeing
activity in syria again one of the first
things we saw under biden and everyone
talked about it was we're hearing
reports that u.s troops were now moving
back into syria of course that's going
to make uh putin very angry because
syria is an ally and and uh russia has a
military base a naval base in tartus so
now u.s troops going back in was once
again aggressing upon russia and its
interests then you go to ukraine the
west starts pushing again
and then russia says okay we're done
we're not doing this i'm looking at gas
prom first time i've really looked in
the gas prom yeah it's not like they
control literally all of the gas it's
120 billion in sales in 2019 they said
it was rated the largest publicly listed
natural gas company in the world
and the largest company in russia by
revenue that's the largest russian
company so biden was trying to get the
oil away from gas prom and start taking
a compete with it with a different
company zeparism
uh it may have been barisma brazil was
an energy company just so happens that i
think there was a cia director on the
board there was a hunter biden on the
board getting paid 83 000. that's some
deep state
no these are just corrupt people man
they're getting like i mean bureaucrat
administrative bureaucrats on the board
of ukrainian gas company
it's it's it's it's as corrupt as they
come
but uh the simple picture is the the
united states and the west were
interested in destroying the nations of
syria and ukraine to save money on gas
and iraq let's not let's uh it's worth
they're sucking that oil out of that
country as we speak libya too
iraq uh iraq a little bit that was um it
is seemingly iraq and afghanistan was
like bolton's wet dream of invading iran
so afghanistan and iraq really allowed
the united states to position a bunch of
military bases on the west and east of
iran and then you ended up with bolton
under the trump administration saying by
this time next year we will be
celebrating in tehran and it was just
like man this guy's nuts because iran is
not
not like afghanistan it is a mountainous
well-defended country with a lot of
people and i think they have really
really great surface-to-air missile
capabilities or like anti-air
capabilities iran or iran iran yeah yeah
i imagine the russian are they allied
with with the russians i don't think i i
don't think so dude i don't know if
you're it's a foreign policy i imagine
they've been loaded with russian
weaponry or chinese weapons probably
this point but this is what's starting
to happen these are the two blocks so um
yeah the um the scary thing is when you
when you consider this
and then you consider what
it's it's almost like the administration
in power right now is a zombie version
of what it was during obama
like
it's trying to walk in the direction but
it's just failing miserably and now with
saudi arabia making these moves they're
not answering his phone because they
don't respect him because why would i
talk to joe biden that guy's not doing
anything
i think the world looks at the united
states and they say they're fractured
within their president it can't speak
straight he'll do nothing to stop us
and there was a
russian tv presenter who said
that we can russia can do anything
including biological or nuclear attacks
and the united states will do nothing to
stop us that's what they said on tv
and that's i believe a legitimate
viewpoint
our adversaries now have well and you
have to look at china i mean china
potentially unleashed a biological
weapon in some capacity and we've done
nothing yeah i was sort of talking about
that on the show the other day the fact
that we argued it was an act of war when
non-government russian actors purchased
46 000 worth of facebook ads but china
releases a virus which is according to
surprise
what what's that release virus was
released
even if it's accidental if a country
accidentally does something which kills
were being told over 800 000 people it's
hard not to consider that an act of war
yeah at least in the uh but within our
borders specifically blocking
congressional hearings i mean we don't
know definitively the answer to these
questions in part because they refuse to
ask the question i think because eco
health alliance was involved that it's
it's multinational at this point who do
you go after you know what is it is for
forex trading is something people do
right foreign exchange buying one oh
yeah i think so how much you know i'll
tell you this
i'm i'm confident the chinese currency
at this point i'm not confident u.s
dollars i'm not confident at all i think
this is fiat the owner is also fiat they
can brought trillions of them i'm not
gonna buy any chinese currency but
bitcoin
for sure can't print bitcoin you can
only create what's already there
yeah yeah i i i'm every day i i hear
more and more news where i'm like how
long has the dollar got left huh yeah no
joke man 18 years it's it's it's it's
like it's the weakest currency in the
world strong you know what i mean if you
look at um
you know
for instance ukraine i mean they're just
currency is brutally when you see those
countries that have trillion dollar
bills right yeah
but
how long you know how long until the
yuan takes over as the reserve currency
maybe not overnight but it looks like we
may be moving in that direction
people look i think when it comes to
these currencies you'll take a look at
the strength of the government that
because the currency is backed by the
strength of the government
if the u.s can't maintain the the force
against other countries to use its
currency for oil they'll stop
and the u.s can't back up their their
words with guns anymore it's not working
russia is proving that china is proving
it
china has a strong and stable
authoritarian government and covet
really shined a light a lot of other
countries are looking at this and
they're like well you know when push
comes to shove china will weld weld your
door shut and execute you
over the united states joe biden will
fall asleep
joe biden was given the keys to the you
know he was given the vaccine he was
given uh all these policies and more
deaths and more cases in his first year
than under trump in his last yeah and i
think part of it is americans are
especially the people that want to talk
about colonization and think of
themselves as globalist they're actually
so sheltered that they can't situate
international affairs they're they're
they live within america that's really
all they understand and they hate people
like trump more than they hate our
foreign enemies and so i think a lot of
what they're doing is purely designed to
play on american politics when really
the world is much bigger than that so i
wonder especially when you see these
npcs with their ukrainian flags and
their bios and things like that uh this
is really just residual russiagate
hysteria where you know russia bought
fifty thousand dollars of facebook ads
oh my god but then the mueller report
everything falls apart and they've got
nothing and now this is like their last
stand of like see we told you russia is
bad
it's just so crazy to me that um
there exist people uh for whatever
reason
that live in that reality
where it's like smilet story was a hoax
they believed it covenant kids hoax they
believed it michael brown hands up don't
shoot was a hoax they believed it russia
gave they believed it ukraine gate they
believed it i'm like i don't understand
at what point does your brain just break
from all the lies that are proven to be
lies or
is there something in intrinsic to their
minds where it's like the lie is better
it's always better to just fall in line
how many of these people actually know
they're being lied to but are too scared
to say anything so they just keep going
along with it how many people are just
so dumb they can't and you never see any
reckoning like you never see just even
regular people that are posting on
facebook and things like that this
mullet happens and they're all up in
arms you never see them follow up i was
wrong or i've learned a lesson i mean i
think we need an apology at some point
because if we're not learning from these
things
uh you know
they're obviously gonna keep keep
happening if there was just some
accountability a tiny amount like you
mentioned just people having to
apologize when they got something
completely wrong if we tried to foster a
culture where people held their friends
accountable for getting outraged over
things that turned out not to be true
far fewer people would but as it stands
there are literally zero social
consequences for spreading lies that
will promote your political agenda
because when it turns out you either
were lying or someone else was lying to
you and you irresponsibly believed it
despite the fact that they have
constantly lied to you in the past and
you were willing to listen to them again
there is literally nothing anyone says
to you to even remotely bring you any
level of shame for the fact that you
have made the system work based on
complete misinformation and that you're
probably going to continue to spread it
in the future
i'm visualizing like humans walking a
tightrope and i'm down on the bottom
watching them all fall off the tightrope
and like i can try and be like hey
here's how you walk a tightrope but it's
so assuming time consuming and
impossible to teach these people that
don't know how to walk it so i'm just
focused on building a better net because
they're going to keep falling these
stupid people these moronic hive minds
and they always have this circular logic
where it's like okay it was fake but the
fact that i could have believed it could
have been real only shows that the
underlying problem is truer than we ever
knew that's so true
that what a crazy statement but ian in
your analogy it's not that you're
watching them on the tightrope you're on
the tightrope and they're bouncing
around and struggling and it's making
you wobble that's for sure and you're
saying guys please
here's how you walk on a tightrope and
they tell you to shut up and then one
guy pulls out a knife and starts cutting
away at the rope and you're like okay we
got a problem the upside of that is all
the wobbling has made me become a better
tightrope walker but it's still annoying
when they wobble the tightrope yes ian
all of the chaos has made me better at
survival yes truth be told thank you for
the assistance looking forward to that
tightrope snapping and then i hold on
and swing like tarzan off to safety like
as you're talking about these people
just buying the lies over and over again
i'm like getting frustrated and then i
start to get angry and like i can't help
those people anymore and i think that's
a really important point i mean there's
an emotional cost to all this like it's
just not fun to argue with your friends
who are saying this stuff that you don't
agree with politically you see the
people that put the effort into really
kind of being congenial and saying well
where'd you get that let me question
this assumption it's easier just to
ignore them because it's just grueling
it's just uh you're on a treadmill and
it's frustrating and uh i think people
just give up and that's where you start
to see this country separating because
it's just not fun i mean who wants to do
it thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm we'll see you all there
you